[Music]
that would have been my sound at your
show and I was again
he's got I'm crazy I just saw myself
he's got a new bus he's got a new vinyl
box that called legacy and we're
breaking down his career so far with a
look at his albums in the collection
next let's talk about gar second live
album triple live these are all songs
that you recorded during your world tour
yeah dude in the comeback tour I saw the
show and it was incredible but what's
featured in two songs on triple live
right yeah she's the bomb she's so good
though you know what people go have you
been singing together forever well yeah
I mean she is saying on we counted it up
the other day just out of fun I think
she's sang on over 90 songs on our
career that's her singing the background
vocal from way back first record to here
so she's as much that Garth Brooks sound
or the cooler part of it then then that
Garth is so she's she's great and all
the same players have played on every
record see you recorded Trish all the
time and I work with my husband you know
Brandon and is it hard like to do it on
the road and work together cuz you're
both artists like Briana and I are my
husband he's my manager and I'm an
artist we're very different is that hard
because you're both artists yeah it's
also your best friend so you got a lot
of good conversations and and we all
want to be like-minded we all want to do
the right thing but how we get there
you're gonna need all the diversity you
can write all the different way of
thinking that you can so me and her are
always cool until it comes to music it
just does because you know you you look
and I go why do you like that so that
song sucks poop oh I didn't mean that I
really didn't mean that and and it's
just how it is in same way with her she
why do you use that player and you're
like well you know it's just it's just
yeah their music is great so we've had
some pretty good Breeden I do that it
will call each other and be like no I
wouldn't that great you can do better
that's what you do is you push yourself
I've never said that if he's ever said
that to you he's a braver man than me
he's pretty bold that's why I think he's
sexy
some weird about me so wait this can't
be right I heard about this and I was
like surely you've done a stadium tour
before cuz you're Garth Brooks dude this
is your first stadium tour so first
amateur try to remember that we spent
eight years in the 90s yeah and then the
tour was done and so went home to raise
our babies so we started in 14 so we've
actually been turned for 13 years which
is crazy when you think of it that way
and so when we came back we kind of put
a tour just like the one we just came
off of in the late nineties just kind of
see where we're at so we've never been
in stadiums but I could tell you this I
was scared to death stadiums were going
to be cold you know and not not they are
the warmest coolest because I'm a guy
I'm the last guy I want to say size
matters and you know when people sing
out to eneter prayers if you guys have
been to a stadium show you could vouch
for me
it's 17,000 people see an answer prayers
will tear your heart out eighty seven
thousand will tear your heart out and
take you to dinner it's fantastic so
it's it's it's more nervous in that
environment or no I don't know it's it's
just because it's so big I don't really
see you as nervous actually I don't know
do you get nervous
yeah you get nervous but the truth is
you stick a guitar in between me and you
they don't send them home right so it's
very sweet so these people if it's if
it's a dive bar 500 or if it's a stadium
of however many thousands they allow you
to suck and be okay they they kind of
let you be you you know scars flaws and
all
it's like a woman that the most gorgeous
thing a woman can wear is happiness
right and just were there confident
happy it's like whoa and that's how that
make you feel when you walk out right
that gear
that you're happy in your comics this
dope so what I love about 8c those
you're not you're like the stadium thing
is cool but you're also doing a dive bar
tour I bars are fun exactly I love like
clubs like oh they're so clear loud
there and you're right in their faces
you're all sweating together everybody
yeah it's fabulous because you're
sitting there and you're just sharing
the same sweat people are you know you
can't you can't get to the bar because
everything is just packed so everybody's
kind of drinking from each other's beers
it's a family oh yeah yeah it's fine
it's old school so it's great and these
dive bars are just cool we're about to
do our last one but I don't think so
I think I'm having such a great freaking
time I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this